reassuring not just the UK public but
the Rwandan government that she means
business home secretaries develop
ratherman visiting graduates at a
training center in Kigali is Keen to
reinforce the government's commitment to
the partnership our Excellence welcome
but with the scheme having deported a
total of zero migrants to the African
nation so far the clock is ticking to
get migrants on planes and into
accommodation ahead of the next general
election on behalf of the UK government
we are absolutely delighted and excited
about our partnership with Rwanda
and not everyone in Rwanda agrees with
the UK government on the policy
I want to make this clear that we are
not against refugees as a patent we are
not because we support welcoming all
refugees that are from Congo from
brunley from wherever because they
choose to come to another but these ones
they never chose to come to Rwanda they
chose to go to the UK so they are not
our responsibility
but with pressure from conservative
backbench MPS to reduce net migration
and the government's immigration Bill
making its way through stages of
parliamentary scrutiny as we speak the
Home Secretary is desperate to be seen
to be on top of her brief
although challenges may be minimal in
Rwanda
soil there Still Remains Fierce
opposition to the concept of Outsourcing
the UK's migration problems to other
nations almost one year on from the
announcement of this deeply
controversial scheme it remains a policy
in theory rather than practice due to
Legal challenges here in the UK
but with deep dividing Lines within the
Tory party over immigration legislation
and with Rishi sunak's ambitious pledge
to stop the boats the government must
appear to be making progress on the
number of people crossing the channel
idea that refugees should not be treated
inhumanely and cruelly when they come to
the UK is not even a political view it's
basic morality if people come on a boat
how extreme must your situation be
the Home Secretary has said it would be
her dream come true to see migrants
blown to Rwanda thanks so much for
coming but she may not be smiling for
long if her Flagship policy fails to see
the light of day Mari Aurora Sky News